أعرب المفاوضون من مختلف البلدان الذين
يعملون على إطلاق سراح الرهائن الذين
تحتجزهم حماس عن تفاؤل نادر
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع بشأن اتجاه
تلك المحادثات. وقالت مصادر لشبكة CNN إن
مسودة صفقة محتملة تتضمن وقفًا لمدة 4 إلى
5 أيام للقتال من أجل
الإفراج الأولي عن الرهائن.  50 رهينة وربما
المزيد من التوقفات بعد ذلك، لكن المصادر
تؤكد أنه لم يتم التوصل إلى اتفاق حتى الآن وأن
هذا النص يتأرجح ذهابًا وإيابًا
لأسابيع مما يؤكد مدى
حساسية وكثافة
هذه المحادثات الآن، وقال نائب
مستشار الأمن القومي جون فينر
لشبكة سي إن إن يوم الأحد إن ذلك  لقد تم
تضييق الخلافات وأنها
هي الأقرب
منذ أن بدأت هذه المفاوضات
قبل أسابيع، لكنه ذهب إلى القول إنه لا يوجد شيء
متفق عليه حتى يتم الاتفاق على كل شيء
مرة أخرى، وسيظهر مدى
صعوبة هذا الأمر بالنسبة لجميع
المشاركين الآن.  فقط كمثال على مدى
هشاشة هذه المحادثات تقول مصادر حماس
أه ابتعدت عن المفاوضات أو أظلمت
مرة واحدة على الأقل عندما
داهمت إسرائيل أه مستشفى أليفا
قضية رئيسية أخرى أه أشارت إليها المصادر هي
كيفية تنفيذ الصفقة بما في ذلك
شحنات المساعدات  الآن أكد المسؤولون الأمريكيون
أن هذا شيء يعملون عليه
دقيقة بدقيقة وساعة بساعة على
مدار عدة أيام، وعندما
سُئل الرئيس عنه يوم الأحد
قال إنه لا يمكنه مشاركة أي شيء حتى
الآن ولكن ما هو واضح هو  أن كل
هذا يجري وراء الكواليس
بشكل مكثف بينما يحاولون التوصل إلى
حل ما بشأن الرهائن الذين ما زالوا
محتجزين لدى
حماس بريسيلا ألفاريز سي إن إن البيت الأبيض